لم تستفق الصين من كابوسها كابوس كورونا
بعد فهي مقبله على سيناريوم مرعب بحسب
تحليل لشركه ابحاث بريطانيه التحليل يرجح
ان تشهد الصين موجه كورونا اطول واكثر
فتكا مع قد يشكل عبئا كبيرا على نظام
رعايه الصحيه في البلاد ورفض التحليل ان
الاصابات بلغت ذروتها في بعض المقاطعه مثل
شنغهاي ويونان وغيرها بعد الغاء قيود
سياسه صفر فيما انتشر الفيروس بسرعه اكبر
من المتوقع في المناطق الريفيه مدفوعه
الجزئيا بالسفر للاحتفالات بالعام الصيني
الجديد ولعل هذه الصوره التي التقطت اليوم
للمسافرين في محطه قطارات شنغهاي تنقل لنا
الوضع عن قرب في الصين
واذا ما تحدثنا بالارقام حول هذه الموجه
الفتاكه رجح التقرير ارتفاع عدد الوفيات
جراء كورونا في الصين الى 36 الف وفاء
يوميا وتقدر الشركه البريطانيه ان وفيات
كورونا الاجماليه في الصين تجاوزت 600,000
وفاه منذ ديسمبر الماضي ارقامنا قياسيه
وقفزات تظهر الوتيره السريعه لتفشي
الفيروس ونقص المعلومات الواضحه حول كيفيه
انتشاره في اكبر دوله في العالم من حيث
السكان
[موسيقى]